hi everyone welcome back I'm Steve
Brenton and I'm really excited today to
tell you about dynamical systems and
this lecture on the anatomy of a
dynamical system how you build them how
you analyze them how you understand them
I absolutely love dynamical systems they
are our models for the evolving world
around us so they describe the rich
behavior of mixing fluids they're how we
build models that we would use to design
rockets and land them we use dynamical
systems to understand the brain disease
networks social networks you name it
dynamical systems describe the evolving
world around us and this is really why I
went into applied math and science and
engineering in the first place is to
model these rich systems that change and
that we interact with these dynamical
systems so this is going to be a video
on the anatomy of a dynamical system
what are the challenges of modern
dynamical systems to describe these
really complex systems of interest and
what are some of the high-level
objectives we have when we're working
with dynamical systems so I hope you
enjoy this this is oftentimes kind of an
intro piece of a longer lecture on how
you would use machine learning to learn
these dynamical systems or to learn how
to control these systems but I think
this can be kind of a standalone little
piece on understanding what are the the
integral parts the bits and pieces that
go together to make up a dynamical
system so dynamical systems are our
models of reality they are how we
describe the world around us especially
how things change and Co evolve in time
so dynamical systems are fundamentally
linked to time and how systems change in
time okay so this is our kind of simple
model of a dynamical system it's a
system of coupled differential equations
X is a vector that represents the state
of our system it is a vector that has
the minimal number set of values that
you need to describe your system so for
example if I have a pen
then that pendulum is uniquely defined
not just by its angle-theta but by its
angular rate theta dot so the state of
that pendulum system is theta and theta
dot in a vector okay so that's what X is
X is a vector of the state of your
system if I'm looking at the stock
market the state of the system might be
the value in all of the stocks and there
might be more information that needs to
go into that state vector if I'm looking
at the weather it might be the weather
condition on a one kilometer grid on
planet Earth okay so the state vector X
can get very very large but it's a
unique minimal description of the system
you care about okay F is what we call
the dynamics it's a set of functions F 1
F 2 F 3 that describe the dynamics of
state 1 state 2 state 3 so the time
derivative of x1 will be given by the
first row equation F 1 and the time
dynamics of x2 are given by F 2 and so
on and so forth so F is a vector valued
function that tells me given a current
state X how does that state change in
the next time instant okay so that is
the dynamics it's a set of functions
oftentimes this is given by like
Newton's second law or something like
that and we sometimes say that this is a
vector field because for every point in
space X this vector field essentially
tells you how the derivative is pointing
and what vector Direction X dot is
pointing at that point in space so it's
a field of these Direction vectors T is
time and this is really important
because in lots of dynamical systems the
system itself changes in time ok this is
super important think about your brain
state your brain state that the dynamics
the equations that would describe how
your brain works are fundamentally
different when you're sitting here
watching a video lecture versus when
you're asleep different dynamics ok so
this is time varying the weather might
change the climate might change maybe we
are actively changing the dynamics of a
system
okay the ocean dynamics the vector field
of the ocean changes in time good you
are all of the variables that we have
active control over so maybe we have
some variables we can manipulate to try
to change the behavior of the system
those are our control knobs and those go
in this vector U so in the case of the
pendulum maybe I put that pendulum on a
cart and I can accelerate that cart I
can drive that cart around and that
would be my control and put you to try
to change the dynamics of my system beta
are all the other parameters of the
system that I don't explicitly have
control over but I might want to analyze
and understand so in the pendulum
example this might be like the length of
the pendulum arm or the mass of the
pendulum and things like that and so
these beta parameters we want to
understand the explicit dependence of
these dynamics on those beta parameters
as I change those parameters I might get
really big changes in the dynamics
called bifurcations
and so these beta parameters are super
important good so that's our dynamical
system now in addition we also have
measurements of our systems so we don't
always have access to this full state X
because maybe my system is exceedingly
large you can't measure all of the brain
all of the neurons in your brain that
would be you know completely impractical
so maybe you can measure a really really
small subset or even some crude
measurement some proxy measurement like
a EKG or EEG or something like that so
you have these measurements in Y and I
now that we've kind of talked about what
is the anatomy of a dynamical system I
want to walk you through one of the
modern challenges so people have been
writing down dynamical systems and
studying them and analyzing them for
centuries
right Newton's law second law is a
dynamical system that was kind of the
beginning of our foray into dynamical
systems but in the modern era a lot has
changed and there are some big
challenges that were able to start
tackling now okay and so that's that's
really what I want to talk about here so
in modern dynamical systems some of the
biggest challenges probably the biggest
one that goes unmentioned in a lot of
cases is that in most situations we
actually don't know
we don't know the dynamics we don't have
a model of our system so for mechanical
systems like the pendulum yes you can
derive you know Newton's laws or the
Lagrangian or the Hamiltonian and you
can derive these equations of motion
from first principles that's like you
crack your physics book and you derive
this system from scratch that's how we
you know used to do things that's how we
do things when we can but for modern
systems of interest we don't have access
to these governing equations and F there
is no known master equation for how your
brain works we don't know the F for a
brain we don't know the F for a disease
Network we have models we have
approximations but we can't agree on one
governing physical law for how a disease
spreads or how the climate works ok so
modern systems of interest F is often
unknown even in systems where you do
know F like the Navy or stokes equations
for a fluid it might be far too
complicated to use and so we would need
to learn a reduced order model in terms
of the things we care about in terms of
the less descriptive state X that
captures the big things I care about in
my fluid the other really really big
challenge in dynamical systems and I
think this this one is really maybe tied
for number one is non-linearity so this
function f in general for systems of
interest is often nonlinear and that
means superposition of solutions doesn't
hold if my dynamics were linear if X dot
equals a matrix a times X everything
would be simple there would be a
canonical closed form solution you could
just write down the solution and go home
we would all be out of business so
non-linearity is what gives us job
security and dynamical systems this is
the real challenge in many systems is
that even small amounts of non-linearity
make it so there are not closed form
solutions in general there are special
classes of nonlinear systems and special
solutions that you can find but there is
no generic one size fits all nonlinear
theory of nonlinear dynamical systems so
that's really interesting and most
systems we care about are nonlinear
other challenges are dimensionality of
the state vector X
so for many many systems this state
vector X might be exceedingly complex I
think in your brain there are estimates
that you have a hundred billion neurons
that's a hundred billion dimensional
state vector just to describe the state
of all of those neurons uniquely
describing the climate or the weather is
also very very massive problem if you
want to get a really good description of
weather on planet earth you need a very
high resolution and Earth's pretty big
ok disease modeling if you want to
actually do a good job of this you
really need to figure out like the
network of how people interact and
that's you know there's billions of us
and there's tons of connections in this
network so it's super complicated high
dimensional dynamics in a lot of cases
and that makes it really hard to analyze
these along with dimensionality is multi
scale so these dynamical systems are not
just big but there's a range of scales
from you know big scales all the way to
really really small scales so think
about whether or or climate you know on
the scale of the size of Earth there are
things I care about their seasonal
changes you know big hurricanes but
little teeny-tiny features also might
matter for the weather prediction three
weeks out ok so you have this range of
scales you care about your brain also is
fundamentally multi scale spatially
there's regions and then those regions
are composed of you know individual
neurons and things but there's also
multi scale in time you're listening to
me talk about this right now you're
hearing words I'm saying on seconds
you're connecting that to things I told
you a few minutes ago but you also have
this lifetime of experience over months
and years so you're extremely multi
scale in time
dynamical systems are fundamentally
chaotic in a lot of situations so not
all nonlinear systems are chaotic but
many of them are and what that means is
that you get a very sensitive dependence
of the outcome of these systems you get
a very the future depends very strongly
on small changes on the initial
condition and the parameters and the
dynamics now so if you have your system
and you change your parameter even by a
little bit you might get very very
different phenomena or if you change
your initial condition a little bit you
might go to very different places and
that makes it really hard to predict
these systems so that's actually why
weather is so hard to predict you know
we can't predict three weeks out because
this is a super chaotic system and we
can only measure the system so
accurately and we only can describe the
equations so accurately and the
parameter so accurately so chaos is is
still a huge problem latent variables
hidden variables again this is related
to dimensionality if I have a big state
vector chances are I'm not measuring
everything you can't measure all of the
neurons in your brain you might only
measure a few of them you might only
have a proxy measurement so latent
variables hidden variables is a big deal
they might matter a lot and you can't
measure them what do you do in those
situations all real dynamical systems
have disturbances and noise and you have
to consider this so your dynamical
system is going to be forced by external
disturbances stochastic forcing and your
measurements are going to have noise and
you can't always just assume that these
are Gaussian white noise processes like
what we do in textbooks because that's
the only thing that we can actually
solve in the real world you're probably
going to have correlated structured
biased noise and disturbance terms and
all of this gets wrapped up into this
concept of uncertainty there's a huge
amount of uncertainty in every single
piece of this dynamical system
I have uncertainty in the model F I have
uncertainty in the parameters beta I
have uncertainty in what I'm measuring
and how it's being measured I might even
have uncertainty in the measurement time
of when I take that measurement I mean
there's all kinds of uncertainty and
that all will kind of conspire to make
this a very challenging problem
okay and I have asterisks on the
challenges because I want to point out
that most maybe not all but most of
these problems can be recast as
optimization problems so kind of
optimally handling noise and
disturbances for future predictions or
estimation optimally propagating
uncertainty in the future and so on and
so forth optimally reconstructing the
full state from limited measurements why
and when I say that this is an
optimization problem you should be
thinking now I can probably start using
tools from machine learning because
machine learning is just optimization
based on data it's building models using
optimization and a wealth of data and so
this is really nice because modern
dynamical systems kind of the anatomy of
a dynamical system allows you to focus
on individual tasks and challenges with
these emerging optimization techniques
okay good so now that we've understood
kind of the anatomy of this dynamical
system I want to talk a little bit about
how we would use it and there's so many
uses I'm just gonna you know briefly
briefly touch on some of them of course
we might want to predict the future
state of the system so I might want to
predict the weather a week from now when
I think of future state prediction I
think of you know what if someone's lost
at sea okay so we had some rough idea of
their initial condition and we want to
integrate where we think they'll be two
hours later okay so that's a future
prediction and the future prediction
doesn't have to be deterministic it
might be statistical I might have to run
an ensemble of initial conditions maybe
I have uncertainty of where that person
was lost at sea or maybe this is the
Gulf oil spill and I don't know exactly
where the oil is coming up so I have a
Gaussian of uncertainty and I want to
propagate that into a future estimate of
where the distribution of oil will be so
that's a statistical or an ensemble
prediction and I'll point out all of
these topics every term in this
dynamical system every one of those
challenges every one of these uses there
are dozens if not hundreds of people
diligently working on these problems
these are not challenges these are whole
careers okay
design optimization that's another big
use of dynamical systems models what I
might want to do is now that I have a
model of my system I might want to
design betas to get a performance or an
output that is desirable
so think Formula one cars or super
yachts or rocket engines I want to
design the parameters of my system to
get some desired high-level output like
drag and lift and things like that okay
and so that requires you to be able to
understand how your system depends on
these parameters now if you do that
optimization in real time based on your
measurements that would be called
feedback control so if you can actively
manipulate some part of your system in
real time those parameters become
actuators and this becomes a feedback
control problem and that would be really
satisfying and incredibly useful in many
many systems if we can actively control
them to some engineering you know
specifications now most of the the first
uses are very practical very engineering
oriented but we also as humans deeply
care about understanding the world
around us we don't just want to
manipulate it we don't just want to
predict it we want to understand
fundamentally how and why it works okay
and these dynamical systems give you a
very kind of intuitive way of
understanding how the world evolves and
what are the rules for how that evolves
and so there's a couple of kind of key
words here that I think are really
important interpretable and
generalizable so interpretable means
that this model is not so complex that I
can't communicate with you about it
we could if this model is not too
complicated we can talk about it we can
try to understand it we can communicate
and interpret this model generalizable
is also really important if I write down
this model I want it to be useful in
other scenarios that I might not have
thought of
so being you know having some generality
and how it how this model works even for
parameters I haven't tested that's
really important and I always think of
Newton's second law is kind of the
ultimate interpretable and generalizable
dynamical systems model F equals MA it's
super simple so we can interpret and
understand it it is very generalizable
it works in so many scenarios
you know for different parameters for
different state vectors and so on and it
fundamentally has changed the way that
we understand with and interact with the
world so we understand the world better
because of that interpretable model okay
good so that's kind of the overview of
the anatomy of a dynamical system I
strongly encourage you to start playing
around with systems yourself pick a
system that you're interested in the
brain or an epidemiological system or
the climate pick something interesting
and start thinking to yourself what
would be a state vector of that system
what would be the control inputs and the
parameters what might be some rules for
how that system evolves in time what can
I measure and start thinking about how
those challenges and these uses fit into
your understanding of your dynamical
system alright thank you